karine déchets golovkov merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors que
doit-on retenir de cette triche est
longue conférence de presse du chef de
la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
en effet cette conférence de presse est
très riche un comme les l'actualité
internationale aujourd'hui
une chose très intéressante est
particulièrement significative qui
ressort de cette presque un an et demi
de discussions
et le caractère particulièrement des
stabilisateurs de la politique
américaine aujourd'hui à l'échelle
mondiale puisque on voit les impacts et
évidemment en afghanistan avec le recrée
qui a été extrêmement mal préparée ou
peut-être justement a permis de
finaliser la déstabilisation des
institutions nationales qui sont mises
en place après tant d'années
d'occupation américaines du pays l'on
voit également le facteur extrêmement
négatif de la politique américaine dans
la question syrienne à la fois avec une
présence militaire illégal mais
également une instrumentalisation de la
question humanitaire et la question des
réfugiés
puisque les états unis autant pays
européens d'ailleurs bloc le retour des
réfugiés en syrie et l'on arrive à se
demander si ces réfugiés ne devienne pas
en fait des otages une certaine
politique
internationale attentiste
on a vu également la question des
relations entre les etats-unis et
la russie qui est dans une phase
extrêmement conflictuel extrêmement
difficile aujourd'hui avec
l'instrumentalisation qui est faite des
structures internationales notamment de
l'onu qui sont situées aux états unis
mais qui ne sont pas des structures
américaines ce que les états unis sans
l'oubli dans leur politique très à dire
ségrégationniste de délivrance des visas
en violation des règles a évidemment
de la diplomatie et l'envoie aussi d'une
manière générale que c'est ces
politiques
commences ta joie on va dire des effets
néfastes peut-être même à terme pour les
etats unis eux mêmes ce qui est le cas
pour ces pouvoirs ne balise qui est
peut-être pas forcément une mauvaise
chose puisque avec la crise à des
navires de guerre et l'australie l'on
voit la question en tout cas que l'union
européenne et que les pays européens si
une européenne elle refuse de se poser
cette question que les pays européens
devraient se poser de savoir dans quelle
mesure l'otan est une institution qui
est fiable pour garantir leur sécurité
dans quelle mesure réellement
peuvent-ils se reposer à ce point dans
les bras du grand frère américain qui
défend ses propres intérêts qui n'a
finalement strictement aucune raison de
défendre des intérêts des pays européens
qui sont emploi en plateforme allemande
et python qui devrait peut-être
commencer à réfléchir à s'assumer
eux-mêmes et peut-être à regarder un peu
plus vers la russie qui comme le voit
autant au niveau du discours qui était
prononcée que de la politique est menée
sur le terrain à une politique qui est
beaucoup plus pragmatique sur le plan
international qui a une politique
apaisée et qui essaie de
dépasser d attitude conflictuelle
en comprenant parfaitement que plus les
conflits net en jeu des puissances
importante plus les conséquences de ces
conflits peuvent être même importante
donc il est important réellement
d'utiliser la diplomatie non pas comme
weiden le disait et on a l'impression
c'est plus pour affirmer à un retour de
la puissance américaine surtout quand on
le couple avec les politiques
concrètement menées sur place des états
unis mais dans un sens réellement d'eux
comme l'a dit lavrov d'ailleurs
d'arrêter l'ingérence dans les affaires
des autres pays sont dans la conception
atlantis des relations avec des pays
mais à en reconnaissant les droits des
pays ces pays qui sont différents qui
ont le droit d'être différent et trouver
un équilibre qui ce qui semble être en
fait finalement le seul de manière non
pas pour abolir toutes les guerres pour
abolir tous les conflits parce que c'est
quand même assez utopique mais en tout
cas pour normaliser les rapports entre
les états aujourd'hui
justement vous parliez des facteurs
négatifs de la politique américaine dans
plusieurs dossiers joe biden a récemment
affirmé que les états unis n'emploierait
plus la force dorénavant pour bien
imposer justement démocratie dans les
pays dans certains pays du monde lui
c'est un guy lavoie vie s'est montré
sceptique
il n'y croit pas vraiment à ses paroles
de joe biden il a raison de se méfier
il a entièrement raison et je pense
qu'il a l'expérience
pour pouvoir se méfier justement donc un
comme l'a très justement souligné à
sergueï lavrov il y a plusieurs manières
d'utiliser la force en tout d'abord on
peut l'utiliser soit même où on peut la
faire utilisé par des tiers que l'on
manipule donc déjà bailon ne s'est pas
engagé à ne pas déstabiliser d'autres
territoires en recourant à des
puissances tierces sinon on pourrait se
dire que le soutien apporté par les
états unis en syrie aux groupes
terroristes armés qu'ils combattent
assad dans ce cas-là ce soutien ne
devrait plus avoir lieu d'autre part
il y à d'autres manières de faire la
guerre pas uniquement avec des tanks et
avec des chars et la guerre qui est
menée actuellement politique économique
et civilisationnel contre l'europe en
particulier dans le sens de la
civilisation européenne à laquelle la
russie appartient plus un politiquement
très concrètement aussi qu entre la
russie comme puissance qui revendique
une souveraineté politique au mois dans
ce cas la montre que nous sommes
toujours évidemment dans une phase de
combat c'est une phase de combat
idéologique qui comme nous savons
parfaitement mais a en face d'un côté
une vision globale east atlantique au
centre et en contrepartie d'une vision
du monde cuiry centriste à quoi va
ressembler selon vous la prise de parole
de sargueil la preuve à la tribune
des nations unies j'imagine qu'il ne va
pas pouvoir parler de toutes ces
thématiques qu'il a évoqué lors de sa
conférence de presse qu est ce qui doit
ressortir du lot selon vous
il affirme en quelque sorte le rôle de
la russie comme
puissance déjà sur la scène
internationale est
actuellement la seule puissance
politique puisque si la russie la chine
pardon est une puissance alternative
elle est économique elle n'est pas
porteuse d'un modèle civilisationnel qui
soit acceptable pour le monde occidental
la russie elle les docks déjà elle
affirme cette
position de garde on va dire de
préservation de la civilisation
européenne 1 par la russie ensuite elle
rappelle que tous les conflits qui ont
été
soulevées qu'il s'agissait du mali qu'il
s'agisse de la syrie qu'il s'agit de
l'afghanistan qu'il s'agisse de l'iran
ou de la palestine par exemple sont des
conflits qui sont absolument impossible
à résoudre sans la russie donc il serait
important que
les états unis dans la vision de la
politique internationale qu'il développe
n'oublient pas qu'ils ne passent pas
faire cavalier seul l'expérience l'a
montré la russie elle a donc l'intérêt
de la russie à travers ce discours que
des deux lavrov tout dallas va être
justement de pouvoir d'une manière
beaucoup plus générale évidemment
beaucoup moins détaillée que ce qui
vient d'être fait présenter cette
alternative présentée cet autre voie qui
est une voix réellement diplomatique
pour le coup qui est une voie qui
acceptent le beauf il a uni les puisque
les et la russie reconnaît que ces
conflits existent à certains endroits
parfois ils sont très difficiles à
surmonter mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne faille pas tenté en tout cas de
chercher une autre loi pessac de la
confrontation et l'ingérence alors vous
dites la russie est là il faut compter
sur cette alternative diplomatique et
d'un côté on a les états unis joe biden
qui dit que les états unis ne veulent
plus être les gendarmes du monde est ce
que la russie bien pour récupérer le
fauteuil ou est ce que c'est parce
qu'elle veut
évidemment je ne pense pas du tout que
très sérieusement les états unis où il
est auteur du cac a priori déjà il n'y a
strictement rien à récupérer qu'est ce
que justement ce fauteuil me semble
extrêmement bien gardé par ailleurs il
me semble que la russie elle de son côté
n'a pas du tout envie de jouer le rôle
du gendarme du monde elle n'est pas un
gendarme elle est un pays elle est une
puissance et à ce qu'elle aimerait
justement ce qu'il n'y ait pas un
gendarme mais c'est qu'il y ait des
états qu'ils puissent défendre leurs
intérêts des états civils et pour
lesquelles on accepte la possibilité
même qu'ils aient des intérêts propres
ce qui est actuellement en fait est
complètement remis en coûte par la
positions atlantistes
américaine
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
voir émerger de nouvelles alliances on a
entendu un sergueï lavrov qui a évoqué
ce fameux contrat des sous-marins qui
est passé sous le nez de la france
et qui est enfin qu'à porter préjudice à
la france qui a été récupéré par les
états unis et le royaume uni il a évoqué
un gagne lavrov des alliances qui manque
de fiabilité alors il a dit on ne va pas
se mêler de cette histoire mais
peut-être qu'il pourrait profiter de
l'occasion pour se rapprocher un petit
peu de pourquoi pas la france même si
même si washington et paris ont annoncé
prochainement des ateliers pour
renforcer cette confiance entre les deux
pays
effectivement tu d'abord et c'est vrai
la russie n'a pas à intervenir de
manière directe dans ce dossier puisque
très concrètement c'est un échec patent
de la politique française et à c'est
aussi une conséquence directe du
renoncement des élites politiques
dirigeantes françaises depuis des
dizaines d'années à considérer la france
comme une puissance et camp des élites
dirigeantes ne considère pas leur pays
comme une puissance il n'y a strictement
aucune raison pour que les autres pays
la considère comme tel donc nous avons
pu prendre cette claque phénoménal
parlée par les états unis qui se sont
non seulement senti en droit de le faire
sans poser de questions sans s'expliquer
mais qui en plus dans un entretien entre
le président américain et français n'ont
absolument pas du tout a cherché à
expliquer quoi qui se passe c'est un
fait c'est comme ça et le président mac
ou français a simplement avalé la
couleur puisque de toute manière il
n'était pas apte à faire autre chose en
la matière donc à défendre les intérêts
du pays
réellement et depuis des années puisque
ce n'est pas nouveau quand même que les
états unis interviennent pensent les
intéressent et quand leurs intérêts
propres sont en jeu pour remettre en
cause des accords qui sont conclues
ainsi réellement les élites gouvernantes
en europe je réfléchissais de manière
stratégique à long terme et n'avait pas
une vision à très court terme et si tu
hâtives effectivement il comprendrait
que des structures comme l'otan sont
donc pas des structures dans lesquelles
toutes les parties sont à un niveau
d'égalité mais sont des structures
hiérarchiser qui sont dominés par la
puissance américaine
ensuite avec un cercle rapproché et il y
as après la nasse des autres partis
manifestement il semblerait que la
france en tout cas après ce qui s'est
passé avec ces navires est été largement
déclassé par le bas et ça par contre
c'est un fait intéressant donc t-il
auquel il va falloir aussi réfléchir si
réellement il y aura après cela un
rapprochement vers la russie de manière
stratégique malheureusement je dirais
que non je ne pense pas parce que
justement les élites dirigeantes
actuellement des pays européens sont
complètement prise en main dans une
logique supranationale et ils m'ont une
marge de manoeuvre même si par hasard il
en avait la volonté ils ont une marge et
manage qui est tellement limité que à
part faire quelques grandes déclarations
quelques tweets outrage et ne peuvent
malheureusement pas dé décider de
branche ou d'autres même l'élection
présidentielle française à l'avenir
changera pas la donne selon vous peu
importe donc pourquoi
parce que l'on a vues si vous voulez la
manière dont la situation évolue on va
dire quasiment depuis chirac nous avons
un changement des visages réguliers ce
qui permet d'affirmer en tout cas en
apparence qui lie à un renouvellement
des élites et les exigences
démocratiques sont limités à un espèce
de changements de visage
en revanche la politique menée reste
toujours la même avec certains
adaptation au niveau social pour calmer
la population de temps en temps mais
nous sommes dans une politique qui est
une politique de perte de souveraineté
progressive est de plus en plus
profondes une politique de
désindustrialisation de plus en plus
profondes ce qui fait que le pays est
affaibli sur tous ces aspects à la fois
parce qu'il ne peut plus gérer si vous
voulez ça marche sa masse non
productives donc ça mars sociale parce
qu'il ne maîtrise plus à monnet parce
qu'il ne maîtrise plus sa politique
étrangère donc les élites dirigeantes
sont en quelque sorte si vous voulez des
espèces d'intermédiaire entre des lieux
de décisions qui sont extra nationaux et
une population qui est mécontente des
décisions qui sont formellement
strictement formellement prise par des
visages qui changent d'aller liger
karine besse le goal of commerce et
d'avoir répondu à notre question mercier
d'avoir merci pour cet éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur invité
à l'université d'état de moscou alors